what i am a massive massive believer in  is really really understanding people  and i think with the way of the world  today with mental health with physical  health you cannot grow and scale a  business in the recruitment industry  without being really really interested  in your people and what's actually going  on in their lives outside of the  day-to-day if someone's sleeping badly  they're going to struggle to recruit  properly someone's eating badly they  might have to be experiencing some  healthy like it's all completely  interconnected and if you aren't  interested in that kind of stuff today  the future you're going to really really  struggle to grow